хімічні заводи завбільшки як невелике
місто їм потрібні мільярди кіловат-годин
економіка Німеччини потребує величезної
кількості енергії але зараз її не
вистачає і коштує вона дорожча ніж
будь-коли особливо на більш енергоємних
технологічних етапах ми вже сьогодні
спостерігаємо помітне зниження обсягів
виробництва
сталеварні заводи важка промисловість
машинобудування для багатьох підприємств
зупинка постачання російського газу може
мати катастрофічні наслідки
Справа в тому що цього разу не всіх
можна буде врятувати
тож час економічного розвитку Німеччини
позаду Невже зникнуть цілі галузі як
можна протистояти цьому
криза прискорює трансформацію яка була у
будь-якому випадку неминуча
промисловість Німеччини надзвичайно
енергоємно дуже швидке зростання цін на
газ та електроенергію особливо
позначається на Хімічній промисловості
хімічна галузь споживає близько третини
загального обсягу енергії яка потрібна
для промисловості це понад 1000
мільярдів кіловат-годин за неї йдуть
металургія нафтопереробка виробництво
скла паперу та продуктів харчування для
багатьох підприємств термін дії старих
контрактів на постачання енергоносіїв та
електрики закінчуються наприкінці року
нові умови - це шок У деяких випадках
називаються вкрай високі ціни на
електроенергію та газ з якими просто
неможливо далі виробляти жодну продукцію
починаючи від миючих засобів та
закінчуючи фармацевтичними препаратами
клеями та іншими товарами Зрештою вони
виготовляються хімічної сировини і це
зачепить весь ланцюжок утворення
вартості хімічної продукції не пізніше
наступного року
[музика]
хімічний концерн Bass раніше отримував
половину необхідного для виробництва
газу з Росії що на початку
1990-х спільно з російською
держкомпанією Газпром басфа побудував
газопровід до своєї штаб-квартири у
людей з гафені на південному заході
Німеччини також консервний фінансово
підтримував будівництво газопроводу я
мав через Польщу до Німеччини з 2008
року компанія брала участь у будівництві
північного потоку 1 натомість російський
газ надходив на підприємство за особливо
низькими цінами
першою помилкою було продовжувати
збільшувати залежність від Росії навіть
після анексії Криму друга Велика помилка
полягає в тому що ми просто проспали
розвиток відновлюваних джерел енергії
хоча ці технології доступні вже 10 років
Вони ефективні та дешеві ми
пригальмували і тепер це приносить свої
плоди тож це її наша помилка в Німеччині
що криза зараз настільки глибока і що
економіка перебуває в небезпеці
газ також використовується для
вироблення електроенергії у Німеччині
електроенергія Тут набагато дорожча ніж
в інших країнах
доводиться платити зараз майже 32 центи
за кіловат-годину середній показник у
світі становить лише 12 центів
дорога енергія стає проблемою для малих
і середніх підприємств що залежить від
експорту досі саме завдяки їм Німеччина
проходила через усі кризи вигравала від
глобалізації без дешевої енергії
німецька продукція стане надто дорогою
на світовому ринку
то який же вихід
енергетичний перехід із Зелена
трансформація безперечно є чудовою
можливістю зробити щось позитивне з цієї
кризи вони можуть і повинні допомогти
нам справді знову стати лідерами як
індустріальна країна як країна інженерів
коли йдеться про сталість і відновлювані
джерела енергії
німецьким компаніям необхідно
перебудуватися
інвестувати у нові технології та
енергоефективність вкладати у
дослідження та розвиток а державі
необхідно терміново розширити
енергомережі та інфраструктуру
[музика]
німецькі та європейські компанії мають
створити перевагу в галузі технології
більш дорога енергія У наступні 5-10
років має сприйматися не як недолік
потрібно стати настільки передовими в
галузі технологій щоб з гаком
компенсувати вище витрати на
електроенергію
перебудова економіки одне з найважчих
завдань у найближчі кілька років часу
залишається зовсім небагато